[Music]
[Music]
welcome to wisdom for life where we
sift through philosophy to find
practical advice that you can use in
your
everyday life hi i'm dan hayes and i'm
joined by my co-host dr greg sadler
and today we're talking about living a
meaningful
life what is it what does that actually
mean what does that entail what are the
challenges to that and i think that some
people
might right off the bat say well i'm
already living a meaningful life so i
don't need to listen to this right that
could be a
significant obstacle that we need to
overcome but i think there's a lot of
ways in which people
encounter crises of meaning or it
changes over time you know we talk about
midlife crises as uh existential
um what do we call them they're crises
but they're also
like situations in which people have to
figure out a new way
forward so um you're the one who
actually wanted to
do this particular topic
um what did you have in mind i mean i
think the word meaning
covers a lot of ground what was this
what was the thing that you were
sort of centered on or what was the
kernel
that you wanted to focus so a while ago
i was writing about
like the locust meaning of where one
places meaning
and the potential pitfalls of where you
place it
because if you place it on something
that is not
you know grounded um especially if it's
something within the world
then those things can be taken away from
you and thus the thing that you base
your meaning in it
from is taken away from you and that's
throws you into
a crisis like existential or otherwise
of like
what to do when you don't have any
control over your meaning
that was a piece that you wrote in
stoicism today right if i remember it
was
yeah so we'll put a link to that um so
people can read it and and check it out
now yeah there's a vulnerability that
you wanted to
call attention to in in that piece and
and
the vulnerability comes in part from
not having things properly set up i mean
is it possible to
live a life where the meaning of one's
life just can't be taken away what
whatsoever
what do you think about that uh yeah
if you can um i guess you know
pulling from some stoicism like really
one of the really basic ideas
is this dichotomy of control there are
certain things you have
complete control over and then there's
everything else that you have either
zero control
over or like only influence over yeah
like the things
if you can somehow place your meaning on
something that is internal for you that
you have complete control over
then you can never have one else or any
uh like natural thing happen to take
that away
so that was the crux so that's sort of
like what you know when marcus talks
about the inner citadel right you've got
this
walled off part of yourself it's not the
only part of yourself i mean you can go
outside the walls but you've got this
part that you can
always feel secure about
yeah and so you usually talks about that
in reference to
finding some sort of equanimity or
tranquility within your own
mind that you you are beset by the
vicissitudes of life
and you're like okay well hold on a
second let me recenter here
um but you know that inner citadel can
be a citadel for more than one thing and
if you can place your meaning in
something that is a little bit more
higher in like an abstraction so for
example
like uh you know a uh
if you're a construction worker you're
at one level of abstraction you're like
they're swinging the hammer and and
putting in screws and whatnot
but then the the architecture the
architect is at another level of
abstraction where he's
he doesn't have actually do any of the
building but he designs the things
of which the uh the workers become
component parts of okay and and so
the idea here would be then to uh take
away
the uh don't put your your meaning in
something that is uh
kind of like ephemeral like being a a
worker in this card
to pull it back up to some place where
um
i can now be a teacher of workers are
like i i am
like kind of this more idealized
version of like okay i build and but i
can then
use my building my the idea of being a
builder and put it into different
contexts i can either build or i can
help design or i could teach someone to
build um and these are things that are
now
uh give you defenses against
like you know uh being hurt or like just
time taking the ravages of us and we're
all going to eventually
pass on well and our bodies are going to
degenerate on the way too
right right and so if as long as you can
say like okay
how can i build even though i'm not
physically building
um that's where you try to like pull
your meaning back to
okay you know this this term meaning you
brought up
a couple other terms that are
good things like equanimity or
tranquility
um another term that we see coming up a
lot with
stoicism and other philosophies of life
is happiness
and so do you think there's a
interconnection between
those terms and i know we're also going
to talk about freedom
and autonomy and and this broader term
of
meaning are they interconnected are they
different things from each other are
they synonyms for each other
you know like a meaningful life if
you're a stoic you could say well you
know the meaningful life or the happy
life is the virtuous life it's a life
where you're
behaving in certain ways and there's
there's some things that you might enjoy
if you're lucky enough but they're not
those aren't the things that make or
break your your happiness
it's whether you have justice wisdom
courage temperance
those sorts of things whether you
fulfill your duties or
you know slag off on them um that's what
would actually
provides you with meaning and and i i
guess i'm asking about this in part
because i
i had a client who became a friend and
he always liked to come back to that
when we were talking about the stoics he
he
hired me to help him like work through
lawrence becker's a new stoicism and
then some other things by seneca
and he he would when he talked about
happiness he would say
you know i'm not so worried about being
happy i'm much more worried about having
a
meaningful existence to what i what i do
you know and he he was a guy who
had position had authority had wealth
but
was much more interested in
you know being a good person getting
getting important things done
uh in his view so what i mean what do
you think about that idea about
interchanging meaning for happiness or
uh like for my conception
of especially the stoic view of this is
that
the the happiness and the tranquility
are the
kind of the the fruits of the labor of
being
virtuous that like okay if you are
pursuing these things
these things follow but that is not the
point the point is to have a
virtuous and you know good life here
yeah and
and if you are thus you know living in
accordance with nature as the stokes
would put it
then you will then the result of that is
that you happen to be
you know a tranquil and uh uh
happy okay and and you know
interestingly too when you
when we talk about virtue it's a very
old-fashioned term right and i think a
lot of people they hear and they kind of
tune out they're like
i don't want to listen to that stuff
right but um
that's that's maybe because they don't
see a lot of
meaning in those terms maybe we would
talk about it as
excellence yeah or or we have to unpack
we you know we have to go that metaphor
that you had about like you know the
architect and the builder
and i suppose we could put like the
subcontractor in the middle
or you know specialist people the
electrician comes in
uh the building inspector so you know
maybe we have to go
back down and say okay well what does
what is it like to be a virtuous person
or not even virtuous necessarily but at
least motivated
by wanting to be that kind of person is
that
is that in fact a meaningful life a life
that
um is rich in in meaning or is it being
kind of boring
being kind of a prude you know passing
up the
and i think we could we could probably
make a good case that
for virtue ethics like whether it's
stoic or aristotelian or something else
um properly understood
virtue is going to be compelling it is
going to be interesting it's going to
open up opportunities for us
to live a richer fuller life that we
we can take joy and pride in you know
i i guess i would also throw in the
especially
you know you got like two conceptions or
at least
there are many conceptions but uh yeah
i'm gonna compare and contrast the
stoics
and the cynics where the the cynics were
like you could take her to leave all the
people around them it's like yeah like
you could be a cynic in the middle of
the city or you could be a perfectly
happy cynic
out in the middle of the um the
wilderness yeah
hermit um there's no need for the
interaction between
other people and uh the stokes is the
human as a
uh a fundamentally
uh social being and yeah yeah if you
can't
be virtuous in a social sense then
there's no point
yeah that's that's quite true um
you could say that the stoics in a
certain sense are more like
you know the platonous and the
aristotelians and that they they see
that as an integral
part of who we are um i mean aristotle
uses this term
human being as the political creature
but it's better to translate that as
as a social creature we're we're
creatures that that
do things in as he calls them um
sharings quinonee um you can also
translate it as community or group or
something like that where we have
something in common with with somebody
else like you and i talking on this show
right now and our listeners listening to
us we're all part of a
sharing in a way right um
so yeah that that's that's a good
consideration i mean the cynics
they you know there are modern day
cynics right there's actually a facebook
group called the
kuno sarges where they get together and
you know compare notes about cynic
practices but i
i think that they're also quite similar
to a different movement that we see
in the present these these people that
call themselves minimalists and
there's an interesting thing going on
there as well
that i didn't think we'd originally talk
about but we we actually should you know
because it does connect up with not just
cynicism but also the stoics and i
i think arguably with some of the other
traditions and with some of the
existentialists that i know you want to
get to talking about in a bit
um can we make our lives more meaningful
by taking things away
that seems to be like the central
insight
of minimalism you know we
shave off the things that we bought
maybe because we thought they were
meaningful but they're actually not
they're not giving meaning to our life
they're actually just clutter or
distractions i mean what do you think
about
that question can we make our lives more
meaningful by taking things away
i i feel that there is
at least something to investigate there
okay that
um especially if you also include
um obligations that you have given to
yourself
and when you have enough obligations
then
all your other obligations start to
suffer for the fact that you
have taken so many things on and if you
are
constantly neglecting those things that
are truly important because you're like
oh well
i have to go and uh see my friend um
and and play a board game yeah every
wednesday night because
we i made that obligation to myself like
three years ago
uh does that also then take away from
other things that might be a little bit
more important
like i don't know some civic
responsibility or like
some familial responsibility getting
enough rest
right oh i have a friend who who loves
to play board games and
uh he invited me along one time
to a friend's house he was very nice and
we enjoyed herself but he works
second shift and so we were playing uh
some board games
third shift okay uh we started at like
11 and we went till like 5 a.m
through my sleep off for the rest of the
week and it was just like it was fun to
do
but like the the outcomes and how it was
a detriment to all these other things in
my life
i had to make that trade-off i was like
that was fun but i don't think i can do
that
yeah that's actually a great point i
mean very often when we
when we hear about minimalism usually
it's framed in terms of like well let's
have less possessions you know people
think about the
uh marie condo i forget exactly what the
name of her
approach is but you know you like
you you try to pair things down have
like i think 50 books
maybe it's 100 books i i know i would
have to get rid of most of my books
um and you do you know similar things
with your clothing and you
ask yourself if it brings you joy and if
it doesn't bring you joy then you thank
it and send it on its way thank you for
your service
exactly and there's something to that
right it's kind of a nice thought
um i've tried it like and it puts you in
a psychological state which makes it a
little bit easier for you to get
rid of things does it that's interesting
at least for me
now is that because um you've
personified the thing in a certain way
or anthropomorphized it now you have
like a relationship
with it but you're ending the
relationship is that the
i don't think i'm ending the
relationship with it okay i'm entering a
relationship with
the either the previous me that bought
it in the first place
or if it's a gift i'm ending the
relationship of the gift
being given because a lot of times like
i'll have like things that were gifts to
me but i don't really particularly like
and so
but i keep them around because i'll feel
guilty giving them up exactly yeah yeah
right and so i was like well thank you
for your purpose you know this person
gave it to me with love i i tried but i
can't
so thank you for what you did yeah i'll
say this
is just an aside when i have gifts like
that and i've i've received many like
that over
the years myself i'm always happiest
when
i can identify somebody else who
actually would enjoy that gift and then
i can give it to them
and i you know as a matter of fact i
don't even like conceal the fact that
it's it's
re-gifting i just say you know i this is
not something for me this is something
that i think you would get something out
of
and i i know i feel good and then they
feel good
i don't know how the original giver
would feel so i don't i don't
want to know more about this you can
look at listen to our very first episode
did we talk about this in the first
episode yeah it was a
christmas um it was like the two-hour
long one
before we did the show yeah right
it's in the podcast speed yeah yeah um
what was what was the title of that it
was uh why it's good to give i think
yeah yeah that's yeah
so let's let's let's come back to the
time crisis
yeah so uh you know we have a crisis of
getting giving a gift or getting a gift
that you didn't like so what are some
crises of meaning
yeah i think i think there's a lot of
cases like this we mentioned when people
you know have a midlife crisis or an
existential crisis
and those usually result when you know
certain factors come together like you
know as you mentioned
talking about the the piece that you
wrote if you've
heavily invested emotionally or in the
meaning of your life
into something that's vulnerable to
something like your job for example
um i mean it's a little bit easier if
you're self-employed
i suppose because then you can keep on
doing what you're doing but you might
not make any money at it
right but but if you're if you're i
don't know
you're working for a company and in the
kind of marketplace that we exist in now
some other company buys them out and
they decide they're not going to keep
you on
and that's that's your identity that's
who you are you are probably going to
have a serious crisis
of meaning meaning that you're you're
feeling that you've got less
meaning in your life that you can
connect with
and you know there's there's actually a
much bigger more generic
question that i i get asked you know
every so often when people find out that
i teach philosophy
then they ask me oh what's the meaning
of life and i'll you know
i'll say i don't know you know i know
what my meaning of my life
is i don't know what the meaning capital
t
capital m is but but i think there's a
lot of people
who are looking for or think that
they've found
you know something something that
universal right and if
and if that lets them down they're
really going to be hurting
and this is kind of one of those really
core thoughts within existentialism
is there's not a the ontological
like is in the world yeah meaning right
uh that that you can just grab that that
is one of these
like things that you have to
contend with and how you contend with it
uh
will really have a major impact in your
life yeah and they're not saying that
you can't
cobble together something from like you
know the traditional
understandings of the meaning of life
right but you have to
um take the responsibility for
the parts that you're you're accepting
and integrating or the
if you're gonna buy into some big system
you know some
some overall overarching thing you're
the one who's deciding to do that it's
not
forcing itself upon you and making you
do that
you you are ultimately responsible you
are you know condemned to be free
you know to be responsible for all of
your choices i want to come back to this
like
how we get into crises of meaning but
but i also i think it could be
useful to talk about you know we brought
up the existentialists
and we've talked about the stoics at
this point and i think
some people would say oh well you know
there's some there's some
inter connections between them like they
both put an emphasis on
you know responsibility for our
situation
and you know they both highlight
how the world is kind of you know
screwed up and
maybe we we don't have uh complete
control over it but we we do control
certain
parts of it but i think a lot of people
would say so the existentialists say
there isn't any
preset meaning to life the stoics say
there is a preset meaning to life
that's a fundamental difference between
them and i want to kind of push back and
say yeah i'm not
i'm not sure that it's so cut and dried
as that i think that um
maybe the stoic especially in modern
times has to be
semi-existentialist and and accept that
you know if if we want to say well you
know virtue is is
uh what we ought to be orienting
ourselves towards that's our choice to
see things that way right
it's not like virtue uh came up and
you know ganged up on me and you know
justice put me in a full nelson and then
wisdom went to town and you know by the
time that they're done i was like i give
i give i'll i'll go with you
what do you think about that idea that
maybe there's more compatibility between
stoicism
and existentialist approaches than
people
give it credit for yeah i guess i've
always
kind of thought of virtue as
at least maybe intersubjective
that is a thing that as
practitioners of um you know
being human beings yeah um
finds that if you if you try these
things
uh for many people these things do
tend to lead to uh certain outcomes yeah
and if if you take these certain value
preconceptions like
this idea of the dichotomy of control
if you agree with this value judgment
then the rest of it kind of follows from
there but i think
really you have to be convinced of this
value judgment
in the first place and i don't know if
you can
ground that value judgment in anything
besides a subjective
position i think some of you i mean you
mentioned experiencing right
experimenting with things
i think a lot of cases we um
we get into a philosophical point of
view that has like a big
you know structure behind it and we're
like well i'm going to try out this bit
of it
and you know it kind of makes sense to
me but i'm not really sure about this
and then we experiment with it and then
we're like yeah actually this this works
pretty good
sort of like um listening to music that
we haven't tried out before
and we're like yeah i don't know if i
like this sort of stuff but now i listen
to it and
it's kind of a catchy tune i think you
can you can dance to it and
and now you start to you develop kind of
an affinity for it
and you're willing to take out a little
bit more okay you know let's see what
else they have to to contribute and then
you start reading some more
seneca or epictetus and you're like oh
there's this other thing over here that
i should try
and you kind of you know gradually
put together you put together a system
within yourself within your own life
but you're the one who's choosing to
take these things on
and you can you can say that um trying
out the experience
shows you that there's something
objective about it or
you're even you know just
inter-subjective it's not pure
like oh i'm just gonna decide on a whim
to do it right it's not it's not
subjective in that sense but
i mean it strikes me that that a lot of
uh existentialist philosophy is like
that too
you know hey you
you oh what i think there's
uh parts of nietzsche
about uh like trying out certain things
and being constantly
you know uh uh experimenting
yeah and um you know it's interesting
you bring up nietzsche
because some of the other
existentialists like i know you want to
talk about sartre and simone de beauvoir
and we can also say albert camus fits
into this camp
they all say okay no no overarching
meaning to life you gotta pick
pick you know what you think but there
is still a value in being
um consistent like if you're going to
pick this then you're you're committed
to this i mean i'm not going to like
hold you to the fire and
say that you can't you know do things
differently but you're going to be
inconsistent and being inconsistent is a
bad thing
sartre de bouvard and camus all
basically say that
nietzsche seems much more willing to say
consistency be damned
you know um well you know like the
emerson quote consistency is the hob
goblin of small minds right
um nietzsche seems to say in some parts
like he talks about virtues for example
and thus spoke zarathustra
and as opposed to most people who talk
about virtues where you know the virtues
are supposed to like all at least be on
the same page
like you might be more temperate and i
might be more courageous or
whatever and so we have you know
deficits that we need to work on but if
i do become more
temperate i'll become more like what
you're like and my
courage and temperance and wisdom and
justice should all kind of
kind of fit together almost like legos
right rachel says
your virtues should actually be like
competing with each other
like at war with each other or like like
uh
jealous of each other you know each one
wants to be the whole of
what you are so like your courage would
be
jockeying for position with your
temperance or justice
um and it's it's an interesting idea i
i'm not sure i buy it but
um for those of us who are kind of
walking contradictions
it might be a bit of a consolation that
nietzsche thought that's
that's the normal condition you know
uh tell me if i have a misconception
here but it kind of
feels like it from the spokes or so
straight he speaks about uh different
states of
of man and the last state is the child
to be the one that is constantly
seeking out new goals to to try out and
like finding that new adventure always
um yeah so i think that also includes
the adventure of trying out different
like
i don't know potentially ethical systems
or or philosophical systems just to
see how those things fit or feel yeah
that
that's an important doctrine early on in
in
book one the three the three
transformations the three metamorphoses
he calls it
and um the child is is like the end
state you start out as the camel
uh which doesn't sound great but you
know it is it is pretty good the camel
can take on all these burdens and live
in the desert
and be you know aesthetic and say um
uh i'll all go along with these things
and endure and i i think nietzsche kind
of sees stoics like like being like the
camel and then you have the lion and the
lion
is a big f u to all the moral norms
you know the the uh there's actually a
fourth animal in there the dragon right
the dragon of thou shalt thou shout
you must take out every single one of
those scales that has thou shalt
honestly yeah and so the lion is the
strong enough beast that can say
no i'm gonna do things my way but
nietzsche sees that as still somehow
um not not going far enough and so the
child
because you're just it's just a negation
it's not actually creating anything
yeah exactly yeah yeah um and if you
think about it
is the child really a beast no it's a
human being
but i don't know if you've ever babysat
maybe you think they are
a beast right
but but they never they pick up and drop
things at the drop of a hat i think
that's
the yeah quality he's trying to exude
yeah it's it's a not being
like borne down the camel carries a
heavy load right the
the lion is is like you said negational
it's against the things that are
standing in the way the child can be
much more
free now i i do want to say i don't
think that thus spoke zarathustra any
more than any
other book by nietzsche is like
completely consistent
it's it's like he throws a whole bunch
of stuff at you and he's like
you know see what you can grab from this
you know
try it out but but i think you're right
maybe this
i wonder if that's like part of his
thinking is
that if he was to create something that
is
holistic and totally works together and
every
little part fits together that would
totally negate the thought that he's
trying to put forward
yes i think that's completely right um
as a matter of fact we when i was in
graduate school
studying philosophy we would have people
who would read nietzsche and they'd be
like well nietzsche says and neutra says
and then we'd be like listen buddy if
you want to be a nietzschean you can't
just like parrot nietzsche because he
would hate that stuff
um so oh back to
or do we want to go to crisis still well
let's talk a little bit more about why
people wind up
in these crises of meaning and and need
to find some new meaning and then i
think
the existentialist stuff is a really
great segue off of that
so we talked about people you know where
they place their identity
um if your whole identity we see this
with like
so-called empty nesters their kids go
away and they've invested like their
whole time is like
being a helicopter parent and now the
the kids are doing
their own thing then they feel lack of
meaning in their life
or if you're associated i suppose if
you're
tied in with a particular political
program
and it completely fails now it feels
like your life doesn't
have any meaning as well and
that's you know that's kind of dangerous
when
and sometimes it doesn't even have to
fail it just has to be threatened for
people to feel like
meaning is leaving their life right
well yeah two more to put forward are
like if you
there's the idea of of uh deaths of
despair
um that there's uh often a correlation
between
what a spouse dies that the the other
one will
usually especially they're like older uh
die quickly after there because they're
they're so wrapped up in their meaning
as being a spouse um to a certain extent
into this
uh this despair that you've lost both a
person as well as
the source of your meaning uh results in
a negative health state
uh and then another one that's rather
salient over the last 20 years is
potentially like the catholic church and
how people became
very disillusioned after some of the
abuse scandals
and so now this thing that was the basis
of their meaning
now becomes this a kind of abhorrent
thing to them and now they have to
grope in the dark trying to find some
way to
reconcile these things yeah and that's
become a problem
i mean that that's like a never-ending
scandal within the catholic church but
one of the things that we've realized
through doing
like you know research across uh
professions and stuff
and across the nominations is that the
rate of
abuse is about the same across
denominations
so pentecostals have been hit with you
know and with uh
similar issues in recent years we also
know too that
and this this goes to like a a larger
crisis of meaning
um you know so you've got clergy
you've got social workers you've got
teachers you've got police you've got
anybody who's got unsupervised contact
with children
the rates of abuse appear to be fairly
similar across
professions and when you find that out
and you start thinking
about the trust that was you know in the
past placed in
all of these these uh professions and
now that's being sort of like eroded
or it could be about abuse it could be
about um
uh whether you can trust police to
actually arrest the criminals
um or protect the public or thinking
about politicians and whether
you can trust them to follow through on
campaign promises
i guess you can say that there is
erosion of a mean
erosion of meaning within the social
sphere right
that results in a lack of trust yeah
that's
and that's a that's a big problem um
once you go below a certain threshold
it's it's very difficult to
bring that back and maybe meaning having
full meaning in a lot of people's lives
depends on having a widespread social
trust
which may not be a good thing you know
maybe if if you
can't get by even if you're in a
situation where there isn't a lot of
widespread
social trust you want to rethink where
you're placing your meaning
right very very that's
one of the thoughts that really like
stuck in my craw
that you know where where do you put it
what is the locus of your mind
yeah yeah i mean it's not to say that
you can't trust people at all
right or like people are no damn good
right um
you don't want to become a misanthrope
um
but you know you do have to be kind of
critical about
where you place your your trust who who
you
how long it takes to build up that that
trust
um you know there's also worries
in a sort of cosmic sense like well does
it mean anything
anyway you know the earth is going to be
destroyed
by you know whatever you know
environmental stuff in another hundred
years or if it if that doesn't happen
and we get our proverbial crap together
and
fix the environment well sooner or later
the earth is gonna
you know be swallowed up by the sun when
it goes red giant
what does it matter anyway we'll all be
dead in the end i think there's
there's some people who feel like you
know when they when they think these
cosmic thoughts
um they don't always have nice warm
fuzzy
reactions to it you know like you think
about marcus aurelius right
a great stoic he thinks about the cosmos
and he finds it a consolation to think
about the fact that we're all just kind
of like little blips you know
um not everybody sees it that way yeah i
mean a lot a lot of people are like oh
i'm just a blip that sucks
but i i like the analogy of on
a car so you get a car and a car is
going to last you maybe
like 20 years or what not um did
was the car meaningless for those 20
years or
was it useful and and so it comes down
to like
we're here right now the experience that
we have
we endow with meaning and so just
because
you know in a thousand years no one
might know our names doesn't take away
from the experience of being us as
humans right now
i think that's a really good perspective
and i think that's
that's a useful remedy when people start
feeling
those you used the word despair earlier
i think that's that's sort of a cosmic
despair
right one of one of those crises that we
talked about
yeah so freedom yeah
i mean let's talk about that you know um
so
try to like get into the meat of this
quickly by talking about a couple of
concepts we
are all all on the same page so freedom
is uh through you you are free because
you always
have a choice and so therefore choose
this is from start
that you have a faculty of choice in the
end that you are the agent of the choice
and it is on all on you it is your
responsibility
and we should we should talk about that
when we're saying that you have a choice
it doesn't mean like let's say you're in
a prison camp will you
use victor frankl's you know man search
for meeting
uh he unfortunately was one of the
people who was placed in the
nazi uh death camps and
you know it's not like he could like
suddenly choose and the door is open
and everybody and the guards become nice
guys or anything like that that's not
what we mean at all
i mean we do have a choice about you
know if you do have a car where are you
going to go with the car
um you're not gonna be able to like turn
your car into a much better car
most likely uh without a lot of work um
we are constrained by our of our choices
we are constrained
yeah but but i mean sometimes the choice
is just of attitude right
it's you don't really have a choice when
they're
telling you march and they lock you up
but you have a choice about
how you look at that do you say oh this
is this is terrible
a horrible injustice has been committed
the world sucks
um or are you like well you know they're
in authority so i guess you know they
must have some reason for what they're
doing that's another bad choice right
or can you be like well this sucks but i
don't have to let it you know
turn my life into misery right
yeah and as uh victor frankel was
talking about in man's search
meaning like those who define their
meaning especially
like um instead of like oh i'm going to
escape or i'm gonna
um especially if you give it a time
period but like oh uh
here i'm going to be uh someone that
tends to the sick
or the the hurt and so now i've created
a meaning within
this place that is absolutely horrible
but i i still have that choice of how i
will act
and react to the situation that i find
myself in
regardless of how horrible it is that's
actually a great example
of what something you were talking about
just a little bit earlier that
just because something isn't going to
continue on
right you might you might tend to a sick
person who's going to die anyway and
you're not actually going to extend
their life you're just going to make
their final
hour less miserable or not even less
miserable but you're just going to be
with them right
you think about what mother teresa's
order would do with
the dying in india that's something
that that's there's even though it's not
going to make
some sort of massive difference in the
whole cosmic
cycle of things even though probably
nobody's going to remember
you for doing that it still is something
and it's something positive
and it can it can bring meaning
right
so another kind of prerequisite thought
is uh tacticity and transcendence
and so facticity is uh that which we are
at the moment
so at the moment where we're two guys
kind of talking about philosophy on zoom
um but we also have transcendence what
we
might become and so uh i don't know uh
greg uh might become a grandfather at
some point in time or he
he might become a pilot hopefully not
anytime soon
right or for some reason he decides he
wants to be a pilot and so he could like
totally change like
a big life change and like oh i'm gonna
drop all this flossy stuff and go and be
a pilot
that's less likely but it is
still there there is a chance of it
there they're constantly growing and
changing
um and yeah yeah we're not defined
solely by
where we are right now or what our past
was or the choices that we we made that
led us to this point
and and a lot of times people
try to create a
meaning or a idea of how they want to
live by trying to reduce
one of these into the other to be like
oh all i am is tacticity
and so like i'm going to be uh i don't
know
a member of the the democratic party and
that is who i am for the rest of my
days and i i'm never going to change or
um
i'm going to you know join the army and
that is that is my thing for the rest of
my days and
remove any transcendence or to try to
uh throw off totally their tacticity of
their life and they say
oh like i'm i'm just kind of floating
here and
i can't have any grounding yeah i mean
somebody who is as aristotle calls them
consistently inconsistent would that be
a form of uh like trying to be
factual in that sense or i would
actually say
transcendence pure transcendence yeah
they're trying to always get away from
anything that could hold them
in one place to you know potentially
reduce
yeah i mean
that that's a useful distinction i think
um and and the two of them come together
i mean at every moment in time
according to these existentialists we
are transcending the facticity that we
we have and and then we fall back into
fact
every time that we've made a choice it
now becomes part of the
the story that we're we're involved in
right
yeah you you can't help but become
like history and or your the things that
you choose like
you can't help but create your own
meaning by every action that you're
doing
you're you're constantly creating your
own meaning uh because
your meaning is your choice and your
freedom yeah and and also
other people seeing you from the outside
they have their own views on what your
meaning
is which may be like totally
antithetical to what what you think it
is
and you don't have an awful lot of
control over that
here's here's a place where i think the
existentialists and the stoics are
quite similar you you don't have control
over what other people think of you
their opinions their
judgments their misconceptions
their their um
you know prejudices any of those sorts
of things right
i absolutely agree uh and that's kind of
some
what what is the play by uh sartre about
the
are you thinking of no exit yeah exactly
and so the
each one of the characters has a
a character of themselves but they also
have a reputation that they
want the others to believe and so the
whole thing is
trying to get them to see them
trying to have the others see them as
how they want to see them
even though that they see who they
actually are and that the disconnect
between those two things
it's a it's a brilliant piece that
that's the one where we get hell as
as other people as a phrase from i this
is a total side note have you ever heard
the
um version the audio version of it that
was done by
partially examined life that had lucy
lawless as
inez no but that sounds amazing it was
it is really quite good
we'll we'll put a link to that as well
because it's
really worth listening to and so
as greg said earlier we live in this
this
space between this liminal space of
being constantly
both transcendence impacticity according
to the stokes
and so uh simone de bolivar
um was
uh worried about people falling into bad
faith and she had a number of categories
in which uh she would define people that
are living in bad faith and so these
people are they
um either don't understand that they
have freedom
or they they see their freedom um but
they use it really poorly
because they they don't really they
don't understand the responsibility
that you have as a free person this is
an interesting point you know freedom
itself
you know we use this word as if it
refers to just one thing right
but part of what it means to be a human
being
is that our freedom is so unconstrained
that we also have freedom about what we
do with our freedom
how we understand our our freedom and so
bad faith or in the french movies foil
right
when we talk about somebody arguing in
bad faith there's like a kind of
trickery going on
a kind of self-deception that is
happening
right that's that's what she and john
paul sartre
are are signaling with that and like
sartre had this example of the waiter
who's like pretending too much to just
be a waiter
or the other example that i particularly
liked is there there's this woman on a
date right and
uh the guy is putting the moves on her
and she pretends like she doesn't notice
it because she wants to
hold on to the moment of thinking that
she's being
treated as a person not being
objectified
and so she ignores his hand like on her
her her arm you know and knowing
where things are gonna come to a
juncture pretty soon so that she can
hold on to that
that moment she's she's kind of lying to
herself but she's not
she's not successful in doing so because
there's always like a little bit of
knowing that you're
you're doing that at the same time you
know and it's it's funny too
um so this is i don't want to derail us
all together but when we feel
what they call imposter syndrome do you
think that's got any
connection with bad faith we like put on
a brave face
and we're like i i you know i do know
what i'm talking about even though we're
like yeah i'm not sure i know what i'm
talking about
or do you think it's something something
you know entirely different or
maybe there's they're part of you know
something that that connects the both of
them or i don't know
i'm not seeing an immediate like kind of
strong connection there that might be
something there but it's not
jumping to mind um
let's talk about a couple of these
categories so we've got yeah um
the sub man and the serious man who are
both um
categories of people who don't
understand
are the the existentialists thought that
there is no ontological meaning or
there's no meaning
out there to actually find that the
meaning
is purely uh a
place that is in the subjective um
and so the subman refuses to recognize
that they are free by avoiding all
questions of freedom and they uh these
people are fearful and easily persuaded
by rhetoric and
uh these existentialists the writers
that we're talking about live through
world war two and they're
a lot of this is coming down to okay how
do i understand
how these people come to make the
choices they did
that resulted in you know uh the
the fascist governments rising up and
then starting world war two
yeah and all the things that people went
along with you know not not resisting
things when they could have
or you know buying into the propaganda
and saying well i guess if you know they
want to do this to these people that's
that's a-okay
um that would be something that the
sub-man uh
or some sub-human person would would
fall into it's like a refusal of being a
human being
it's like well just we're going this way
apparently
yeah um the serious man is that person
that like that that's got that
that lifelong devotion to something they
think they've totally got it figured out
and they've placed their meaning in some
other group
that subsumes them and so they they
sacrifice their freedom
to group her ideology becoming an object
of the group or ideology
and not choosing for themselves here's
an interesting question
now she doesn't consider this at all
because it's a phenomenon of our time
could you be the serious person by
buying into and like you know becoming
an important person and curating stuff
within a fandom
where you're like this is really really
important
you know uh we must you know articulate
this and go to all the cons
and you know have everything set up the
way it ought to be
um i mean we don't think of fandom as
like
it's sort of the opposite of seriousness
right but maybe
certain ways of being in a fandom could
be like
being a serious person i would
absolutely agree that
uh that a fandom could be the the
serious man the basis of
you know uh uh meaning that someone
like gloms onto okay yeah that's
that's i mean that's not a very
technical term gloms onto but it's
actually a really good term because
we're all i think we're all familiar
with it right it's part of our popular
culture it means like
somebody it doesn't originally belong to
them
and they see it over there and they like
they like
almost like wrap their arms around it
and try to make the thirst right
right and and then they
they derive their meeting from is like
oh well now i'm an expert on this
particular fandom and then they gain
prestige and reputation among those
other people have all
also glommed onto that same idea they're
they're like the personification of it
yeah i don't know if i ever told you
this story now this isn't a
very you know abstruse kind of fandom um
there this was told to me by one of my
professors when i was in grad school
and it was about a lock conference that
he went to a conference on john locke
and there was a there was a scholar who
had written a lot of
articles and a couple books on john
locke and apparently this guy had really
identified himself with john locke
and there was like a symposium and they
were talking about well john locke
thinks this and john locks thinks this
and this guy got mad
he got up and he slammed his hand on the
table and he said
that is not my doctrine and then he
suddenly caught himself and everyone was
like what
that he was like a big name right so
yeah they're gonna give him some
latitude
and you could tell that the guy had
forgotten that he was not john locke
wow that could happen sometimes yeah
but isn't that exactly what we're
talking about here that identification
i am the whatever yeah so
now there are three other groups that
i'm
simon simone has a problem with
uh here on so the uh they
they do realize that there's no
ontological meaning
out there to grasp but they use it
really
poorly and so we have the nihilist the
adventurer and the past
the passionate man and the nihilist um
gives up uh any values and goals because
it's like oh nothing has any meaning so
i just i give up which is kind of a sad
state of affairs
people like that can be very dangerous i
mean i think
many people's experience limited
experience with the neolis is thinking
about the big lebowski
and the neolis showing up and say we
believe in nothing
but i mean somebody who really does
believe in nothing there's
there's nothing holding them back right
right
um but there's there's never anything
holding the back everyone has freedom
but there is
responsibility that comes with freedom
and just because you don't think you
have responsibility doesn't mean that
you don't have a responsibility
yeah and so this is also the problem
with both the the adventurer and the
passionate man
who don't realize like they realize that
there's
no actual meaning out there and they
have now defined
their own meaning for themselves but
their
their pursuits of either the the
adventure is
uh doing things just for the the sake of
doing them
the conquest of having doing them and
the passionate man goes i'm gonna
to do things like that or passionately
pursue
for them and in themselves um and not
just the completion of them
but both of these treat other people as
objects and that they don't realize that
they have to treat
that their freedom um doesn't give them
the latitude to
not treat other people as also free and
to not oppress them while they're doing
these things yeah that's right the
adventurer as
simone duvoir talks about it is the
person who
the whole world is basically like extras
in their own
movie right and so they can gun them
down if they want to
or exploit them and then the passionate
person you know like they might
passionately love another person
but they're they're treating that person
essentially as an object
that is given meaning because of their
passion they're not
their love is not a genuine response to
i don't know the lovability of the other
person you know
and we see a lot of relationships like
this
you know um usually they fail eventually
but they can be quite intense for for a
while
and you mentioned you know they're
they're not they're not treating other
people
as real people which means they're not
resp they're not respecting that freedom
exists just as much in the other person
as it does
in in oneself to treat these
subjects as objects to reduce them to
objects
yeah um and and so the the conclusion
she she comes with like you know all
these people are like kind of
moving towards this realization
hopefully at the end
on if you're gonna move through all
these that you you have freedom
to make all your choices unless you get
to choose your own meaning
um but you your your freedom comes with
it responsibility
and if you are using if you're you
failing at your responsibility to uh
treat others
as free individuals um not only is that
like
bad in the sense that you are oppressing
people in this
things but you're also hurting yourself
because
uh in simone's um ideal
that you're trying to maximize your
freedom
and you maximize your freedom by having
more
other free people around you right
who or your freedom can be at least
partially compatible with
you know you know and it just occurred
to me
one of the ways in which you would
respect other people's freedom
would be
a sort of receptivity to hearing what
they have to say about what you're doing
with your freedom
right if they're like hey man you're
being a jerk
and you're like shut up you know my
freedom
um i think you're not respecting the
freedom of other people right
i mean if somebody's constantly like
running behind you and saying jerk jerk
jerk
character okay that's different but
um we in order to be re
in order to to realize what you're
talking about
having a meaningful life that one that's
connected with other people
we have to be willing to hear them out
because
we're all we're all kind of messed up
right and we're going to make mistakes
and so i mean they can be mistaken in
diagnosing our mistakes but we probably
do need to provide them the space
and respect to be able to to say
something
at some point in time right yeah
and to not yes you know blow up or or
tried them for like saying like hey i
need these
things as well that like yeah i'm not
just an object here i am a subject
yeah well we're we're getting close to
the end of the hour should we talk about
a very
quick uh practice
so epictetus in his end caridian talks
about a worry a lot of people have
in practicing stomach philosophy and i
think it could be something any sort of
philosophy as a way of life
where one would say oh if i do this sort
of thing
i'm not gonna be somebody and he uses
those words i'm gonna be a nobody i
won't be able to like help my friends
nobody's gonna pay attention to me
and this is a worry that a lot of people
have today you know
a lot of people are worried maybe i am
nobody maybe i don't matter
maybe my life is meaningless and
one when when that happens i i think
that it can be productive
instead of saying oh no no you know i
definitely have meaning well think about
where you've placed the meaning of your
life
and then say am i getting what i want
out of like trying to pursue a ton of
money or be popular or stuff like that
or you know do you want to pursue
something else like say stoicism or
existentialism or some other
philosophy as a way of life that would
orient you towards something
that will provide more genuine meaning
that's robust that lasts that you can
you know uh keep coming back to over and
over again
i mean what's what do you think about
that we still have a little bit of time
uh i think you and i have done that sort
of instinctively
with embracing the kinds of philosophies
we're interested in
right that yes the idea that the
your reputation is not um
what defines you yeah it's a indifferent
and stoic
velocity as well as as we talked about
the
um was it no exit um right
other people are gonna give you your
reputation and you're gonna you're gonna
have it whether you like it or not
right
yeah so um i think we probably have a
lot more to say about this so i think
we'll pick this up again
in future uh
future uh episodes right oh you don't
you think that we couldn't like cover
meaning
oh yeah or do you want to lead us out on
uh
yeah some final thoughts so uh
we're going to leave you with the words
of simone de beauvoir
freedom is the source from which all
significance
and values spread it is the original
condition
of all justification of existence
[Music]
you